HAI QI: What is neuroimmunology? it's a
study that the bi-directional influence
or interaction between these two arguably
most complex physiological system in our body
VOICE OVER:. Hai Qi studies the connections
and interactions between the
brain and the immune system.
HAI: They're both based on a network of
interaction of the cells. One case neuron,
the other cases you know lymphocytes and
many other immune cells. They both have
memory ,they both play a role in defense
and in in reaction to external stimuli
etcetera, and they cross regulate each other.
VO: But could these interactions
be harnessed for health benefits,
can we influence our own
immune systems with our minds.
HAI: I was a trained as a supposedly clinician
um back in the in the 90s actually last century.
But then I I didn't go practice medicine but
went to grad school in the United States. I
became interested in T cell biology. Then
after graduate school I went to National
Institute of Health where we study T cell and B
cell interaction for germ center response. So I
became even more interested in the intricacy
of how T cell regulates B cell response.
VO: And since setting up his own lab
Hai has continued to investigate how
these two lymphocytes collaborate with
each other and how these processes are
regulated in the body and this
interest eventually led him to
neuroimmunology understanding how the
brain influences the immune system.
HAI: I, as a child growing up observed that that
many people claim their thinking exercise or
Qigong that type of a practice will bring out
a health benefit you know in Chinese there's
a word we say Miǎnyì lì [免疫力] loosely it means
you know the the, your capability of sort of a
general defense against the variety of potential
pathogens or insults uh so it has been claimed
that the mental state would influence that
ability so making me wonder what's the
connection between our mental states and our
uh with our sort of a physical health state.
VO: So high and his colleagues looked to
animal models first attempting to identify
and remove nerves that could be providing
the link between brain and immune systems.
HAI: With the hypothesis that if we remove a
nerve that potentially transmits a neuronal
signal into a lymphoid organ that can
regulate the immune response then we
should see a difference in the immune
response that animal will generate.
That's how we started and then initially
we indeed observed that by removing a
spleen nerve in a mouse model uh then
following a model antigen immunization
the antibody response of the mouse was impaired .
VO: The team found that the plasma
cell response - the cells that produce
antibodies in response to a vaccine - was
influenced by activity in the spleen nerve.
Removing the nerve reduced production
of plasma cells following immunization.
HAI: Then we trace this neuronal signal
carried by the spleen nerve upstream,
then we we find that there are at least a two
important brain regions in the central nervous
system that are important for this spleen nerve
dependent promotion of plasma cell formation.
One is called amygdala the other
is paraventricular nucleus.
VO: These regions can respond
to certain behaviors or stimuli.
For the mice in the experiment this
was mild stress, they were placed on
a transparent platform too high
for them to happily jump off of.
HAI: Under that mild stress in this
two regions there are special subsets
neurons called a CRS neuron will be activated
and these neurons and their activation cause
a signal in the spleen nerve that transmits into
the spleen and that signal is presumably read by
a special subset of T cells and that T cells will
convert that nerve signal then relay that signal
to to B cells and that signal promote these
B cells to become and expand as plasma cells.
VO: They had found a route for a behavioral
stimuli to modulate an immune response in the
mice and that opens the door to some fascinating
possibilities if it can be replicated in humans.
Hai thinks this link could offer a new
target for drugs aimed at manipulating
immune response but this isn't the
only outcome he's interested in.
HAI: One can start to imagine that at the
conscious level that that we might have
certain brain exercise that will influence
the function of the limbic system then
subsequently influenced how our immune system
operate. It seems to become possible that
one day we could design a thinking exercise
that actually boosts your antibody response.
Potentially you can have a a
central nervous system memory
that can have an impact on
a memory immune response.
Yeah I find that's a that's a very
um intriguing and and exciting.